[Music]
if you spend your day looking at a
screen whether it's a television
computer or phone you're looking
at blue light and that can affect your
sleep
i'm joined by alina conley to tell us
about
blue light blocking glasses for kids
thank you for joining us elena tell us
about
i spy by the conley kids how did this
come to be
well first of all thank you so much for
having us and you know
it was really something that came about
because i had a colleague who was
recommending that i purchased some blue
light blocking glasses because i was
dealing with some insomnia during my
pregnancy
because i was having so much screen time
from all of the work zooms
and i kept thinking my kids have been
dealing with
some insomnia and staying up late this
could possibly be
something that's affecting them too now
that so many kids are in virtual school
so me and my husband decided that it
could opportunity
for us to bring some fresh to the
marketplace based on
the needs of kids but also something
really cool and fun to do with our
children to teach them about business
and entrepreneurship
you're definitely right about kids
spending way more time on their
screens with virtual learning and
everything that's going on and that can
negatively affect us
now these are glasses for kids what
makes them
fun for kids so
we have considered blue light blocking
as a new super power so what we do with
our glasses is not only do we protect
them
from blue light rays that help them
sleep better but we position it where
the kids get excited to keep them on
we know that kids don't get off of those
gadgets
they loving watch tv at night and so we
tell them that they're starting to blast
the blue light with their superpowers so
all of our glasses are named after super
powers as well as
characters that are some of our kids
favorite
and it just gets them really excited to
get all of the fun colors to go with
their outfits and make it fashionable
and just another reason to
you know get excited about school when
you can't be with your friends they are
so
cute i love all the different styles now
you got to tell us how much do they cost
and where do we get them from
absolutely so they start as low as 12.50
we have a collection that's 2 for 25 we
also sell glasses for parents that can
range anywhere from 20 to 35 dollars
because of course parents need to
protect their eyes as well
and you can purchase them at
ispyconleykids.com
they are so cute thank you so much we'll
have all the information
on our social media too las vegas now
will be
right